so we're gonna talk spoilers and we're
gonna save it for after so you guys are
safe but first I want to know did you
guys know you were both reading for the
same project on this one all I got here
for your there I got there I got it
first um so I was there during the whole
process of them trying to find different
people for Stanley and I was there kind
of during that whole process so when I
heard he was gonna audition site no I
was happy that I get to actually be with
you know act with my friend who's
playing my friend
so um I thought that was just gonna be
roll real fun and I'm so glad you got
the part was it real trippy when you got
the role and it was another stand yeah
well I was like well like it's like okay
so we're working with people have worked
on stranger things obviously we know
someone from there and then I saw in the
email I was like Sophie Lewis cast it as
Sydney and I'm like oh okay and then
character named Stanley so like
everything was kind of like everything
came together for this and it's like
it's fun to be playing another Stanley a
very different Stanley and yeah I just
I'm glad to be working with her again
and I think we made something kind of
fun you did as much as I know you're
capable of much more I would be really
amused if you just got more and more
stands over the course of your career
you just and this different in their
family Cinematic Universe is what people
have been calling it okay yeah I'm
totally into this idea as well did you
guys find your real life friendship kind
of coming through the material at all
because the connection there if it
really does leap off screen and I was
just completely charmed by it
oh thank you i I I guess it did
hopefully we didn't really I mean we all
got along on the set of it one obviously
everyone there's plenty about that but
we didn't really get a lot of screen
time together
cologne to interact with each other our
characters interacted sometimes but
especially with this show we're able to
really express our friendship and you
know where we're already we're already
super comfortable with each other so it
makes it so much easier when we have to
act together and rely when we get to
rely on each other for that so yeah it
makes our jobs easier to already know
each other
I like your on that and because we are
in the spoiler zone right now I don't
like asking the generic question but I
want to hear just what was the most
challenging scene for you to film
whether it was something that was more
dialogue driven or maybe something that
relies more on sets powers ADR was a lot
of ADR the whole thing ADR based so that
was the hardest for me don't know right
you know not that funny thing the last
scene we shot on set was the one where
we're sitting on a table in the library
planning out our heist mission the last
shot took about 11 takes because someone
didn't remember their line okay but for
our lines correctly and no one was
telling us that we were saying them
wrong and then we just sat there for
like a while and we're like what are we
doing wrong it was a lot of fun is it a
situation though where the line does
kind of seared in your brain now no
because like there used to be like
another name and then they like cut it
out in a VR but there was like another
name that we had to say so we had to get
Dawson's off to get to Dawson's office
we need Whitaker's keys and then get
what it's worth hated whatever and it
was like it was fun so the end result of
this is if you really had to do that
heist you would mess it up somewhere oh
no like the stark like as soon as we
open the door he turned her off can you
actually solve a Rubik's Cube I can all
right I like I don't have a much is
there is there a trick to it
it's just algorithms like knowing where
color is and yeah it's not too difficult
well I get like halfway through the
explainer videos on YouTube and I'm like
I I just took the time and I sat down
I'm like I should probably solve this
cuz I had one feel like everyone has one
but yeah I just took the time and I was
like okay he's pretty simple he put it
in there to densha yeah well I was I
forgot like I I was just doing it on set
one day and then the other thing was
like you should do that you should do
that on the show yeah is there any other
elements of your characters that were
purely you and weren't on the page
before that we could see on screen
there's a one scene where I yell at him
for doing that
yeah and that was kind of honestly it
was annoying I was really flat cakes so
yeah I was a little bit annoyed so when
I yell at him to put that down I'm kind
of genuine did you guys ever come up
with a like a name or a term firsts its
powers because I guess it's not just
telekinesis it's more than that so did
you guys refer to it as anything no I
mean I yeah it's not kind of refer to it
as telekinesis like I mean Brad's head
exploding is like kind of like making
like everything go apart like
technically nice telekinesis but maybe
she can put bombs inside people's heads
I don't know that'd be an interesting
power what was it like shooting that
scene in particular what is kind of the
movie magic happening behind the scenes
yeah well yeah there's a lot of before
an app like it before when I'm looking
at him and after I'm all drenched in
blood so there was a big you know
transition with my body and his body and
yeah there's the whole double like
that's the first thing he saw was the
double on the floor with all the blood
and everything and that was that was
real interesting got got good pictures
of me with that
and yeah I know there's a lot of you
know special effects with you know the
blood exploding and everything but I
didn't have to do anything about that
that was all the special effects people
said and it comes together quite well in
the end that is really a very well
worthy way to end the season so when you
guys were first reading the script and
you hit that point were you shocked that
that's where it ended and what questions
that you have for Jonathan about maybe
what could happen next well I thought
that was the perfect way to end
something like this especially it was
kind of Jonathan's kind of dry quirky
humor and way of working the ending just
seemed pretty fit yeah I mean it felt
kind of like oh that's a that was quick
but I feel like it's like if you know if
you're paying attention while you're
watching I think everything kind of
leads up to that moment and every it's
like foreshadowed often obviously
bread's nose bleeding and stuff and all
that fun stuff yeah everything kind of
comes together and I feel like that it
couldn't have ended in a better way if
you guys could pick one thing about your
characters that you would like to see on
screen and other characters more often
what would it be
there's like a million and one answers
for both of you absolutely I don't know
something more serious I think or maybe
I don't know actually does this I like
Stanley a barber a lot I don't know I
I'm saying with him I don't know you
want to play Stanley well yeah because I
want to play it Stanley barber that
would actually be a kind of fun like
side video to do just a flat rolls and
see what happens
yes been off show with everyone playing
Stanley